[Music]
am i have here is this your game right
what is your name sorry Peter
Emer okay so you're white in this game
again okay fair enough
so split into Thanksgiving open a couple
of months ago right few months ago all
right so our player is why he plays d4
Knight f6 c4 and six
alright so this is what's considered to
be the beginning of either the Queen's
Indian or the names of Indian defense
which is a very common defense at the
top level but it's a little bit more
difficult to figure out for especially
for beginners on how exactly the pieces
are developed because one piece
specifically this Bishop on b7 sometimes
it's not so easily
developed specially unlike the Catalan
type of variations where you cannot
really put it on b7 but okay of course
at the top of the world this is probably
one of the most popular replies if not
the most popular reply against d4 is to
come up with this new Missouri Indian
setup now you play the move a3 and
although I guess I kind of understand
the idea is probably to prevent this
Bishop coming to before and that's okay
you might want to be a little bit more
aggressive with white now when we used
to begin the game White has an extra
move and usually you know the less than
2,000 level that's not right that's not
really a big deal you know want to move
whatever people over coming by style or
by different openings or whatever so
it's not such a big deal but you want to
get into the habit of using that tempo
to the maximum of its advantage so you
want to be able to develop as quickly as
possible and in this case a3 although it
does prevent the Bishop from coming to
be for what ends up happening and what
happened in the game is that you get an
Orthodox type of queen
gambits the Orthodox being after 93
simply d5 one of the many ways of
playing this position but you're gonna
be down a temple because your movie 3
wasn't particularly useful see this
Bishop Hassan said I must go to before
that's my only purpose in life I mean he
could still go to e7 it could still feel
Cairo for Allah knows it hasn't
determined its position yet so since it
hasn't determined its position it
doesn't really make sense to take it
away from him in some cases when you see
grandmasters play either h3 or a3 is to
really prevent from a certain pin or a
certain position from the bishop that's
that really can only go there for
example in the in in one of these loves
the Schleck there's love in this kind of
positions after g6
it's very common that play continues
like this and now they play h3 the idea
is that after h3 Bishop a5 is too soon
it doesn't really it has its own
problems but usually black castles and
after Bishop d3 it's not so clear where
this bishops gonna go it doesn't really
want to go to d7 only six okay it's a
little iffy and it doesn't it can't go
to a five and I took g4 away so now it
kind of makes sense because the bishop
doesn't have any development squares but
in the line that we're looking at in the
game it seems it feels a little slow so
I would suggest probably Knight c3 is
the most beginner friendly move you
simply develop towards the center wait
for him to go Bishop before g3 leads to
the Catalan positions which are pretty
popular nowadays a knight of three
usually leads to e there are strange
Orthodox or a Queen's Indian Defence
with b6 all of which are interesting
possibilities okay so a3 happened and he
went d5 which makes sense so Knight c3
and now you wish you could do something
more than a three now so probably blacks
equalized but to be fair not more than
that it's not like blacks better or
anything he blacks just probably
equalise so 9 bt 7 okay III now III
although it turns out to be ok sometimes
you have to ask yourself if this point
is really hanging before you want to
play III a good rule of thumb is like if
this point is on a 6 or this point is on
c6 usually the pawn is hanging so you
want to defend it or you want to
sacrifice it depending on your style but
if there is no pawn there you can maybe
use this tempo again to do something
more productive and try to develop
because at the moment this is not this
is not a threat say for example I go
Bishop g5 if he takes I can play e3 and
if he defends this with a knight a
common trick is to take it anyways and
after Knight takes e4 you check
recovering the piece say he develops a
queen takes and now here when black has
the pair of bishops but white gains some
space because you got rid of his central
pawn so it's a little bit of a trade off
that's generally considered to be
favorable for white on the other hand
it's also possible to be even more
aggressive and go e4 and in some cases
e5 is gonna be a little bit of an issue
for black so those are possibilities and
you played III which is not bad it's not
like it's a bad move but it's a little
passive in the sense that your bishop on
c1 okay he's not thanking you for that
move you know he really wanted to go out
of the pawn chain before you play d3 so
it's not a bad necessarily thing but
okay your bishops gonna suffer a little
bit so he plays c6 which doesn't really
make any sense because if you think
about it the point of c6 is usually to
take on the c4 or threaten to take on c4
which usually forces white to play e3
but you already played e3 so well what's
the point I mean he could have done
pretty much anything else
so c6 Bishop d3 it's fine looks good to
me
gasps oh no no no you play 93 first 9f
357
and now there should be three okay yeah
looks good castles Castle so and he
wants c5 right is that he did so a1c 65
yeah there's something wrong with that
logic right okay he could have gone c5
immediately yeah basically now a3 looks
particularly good that being said it's
not necessarily bad for a block although
this setup in particular should be a
little bit better for white for a few
reasons
first this Bishop is more active than
this one this is a very slight
difference but you know at the Grand
Master level this usually adds up the
point is that here black white can maybe
create threats against the king side in
some variations the black cannot on the
other hand this Bishop is more exposed
so for example if you take you don't
want to take because Knight takes e5 and
then this Bishop is under attack so it
pros and cons but if the bishop should
be better on d3 anyways so here comes a
very typical question how do you get rid
of the central pressure do you want to
initiate the change the exchanges or do
you want you to let your opponent that
initiate the exchanges that's always a
difficult question in chess and usually
the problem of that is that it's very
specific to the position so it's not
like a general thing I can tell you all
you can always trade off all the pawns
in the center and you will always be
better because that's not how it works
in this case specifically there are both
arguments for and arguments against
trading off all of the pawns so so
argument for I would say is that if I
take take take take I could probably
just move the bishop to c2 and then try
to follow with b4 and try to pressure
this pawn on d5 so you got a nice little
fun to work with but on the other hand
black does gain a lot of activity you
know let's see how his pieces
sovereignly are all out so that's an
argument against trading off all the
central pressure I like what you did in
the game better than trading off the
pawns I think that Queen c2 makes more
sense than anything else in the position
so Queen c7 and now you take and now
there's a little bit of a difference
because this Queen I'm not so sure
wanted to go to c7 in case there was an
isolated pawn so I think this is good
for you Queen c7 pawn takes pawn takes
92 is logical actually that move is very
common c4 is the strategically dubious
move because usually after Bishop f5
what ends up happening is that white can
easily prepare a break on e4 or focus on
the kingside and it's not so clear that
this pawns are gonna go anywhere so
that's usually not so desirable for
black he played b6 which also little
more sedate and probably a little bit
better and you play Bishop d2
and now here's kind of like the thing
about Bishop d2 you kind of want it to
play wish up at four
well that's illegal so this is for you
this is where III comes to us a awkward
move right you have to play Bishop d2
but maybe was better to put the bishop
on a diagram where it's actually happy
and like maybe play b3 and Bishop b2 and
then okay black does they want to get
him to keep himself an isolated pawn
without any compensation and of course
at the moment he cannot do this at all
because the queen is is facing each
other but since say that for some reason
the queen defense he still doesn't want
to take on d4 so that's gonna be a
somewhat annoying pressure for black for
quite a while I think Bishop d2 is fine
but I think the bishop would have been
you know long diagonals for bishops is
the rule so he plays Bishop b7 you
develop like normal
he plays ninety four which is a little
dubious you don't really want to put the
knight on such an aggressive square for
no reason what ends up happening here
more often than not is that black really
has to justify his pawn structure and
now say that you take on c5 right what
can black take with what's probably more
natural any ideas okay let's say the
point on B all right so what what is
this pawn structure called
this specific one the hanging pawns here
hanging pawns are this pause usually on
the C and D files and they're called
hanging because they can only protect
each other
they cannot be protected by a pawn on
the B file and they cannot be protected
by upon on the e-file and it's a very
specific structure in chess what ends up
happening here is the black really needs
to initiate a King side attack to
justify having such a weakness such a
long term weakness but here there's
nothing going on so if I just play
something like Knight f4 immediately I
think that blacks already a little bit
in problems so wait where'd you play
Knight e3 is okay but the promise that
you're just making him play moves that
he probably wanted to play anyways he
probably wanted to play a five not that
it's that good of a move but I think
your next move is the real mistake so
you remember when I said that after B
force sorry at that after C for this
part of a thing when I go anywhere well
that was true where there was a pawn
holding him back but now that you so
gracefully moved it out of the way you
know he's going to have a passed pawn
and now you're gonna have to pay
attention to it for the rest of the game
so that's maybe not so clear that you
really wanted to play this then you
played Queen a to a little bit clever
because now if he takes you take his
queen right so that's not so good
b5 may be an unnecessary move but by no
means bad they should be one so what
ends up happening is here that you're
playing a little bit planless because
now you don't have any King side
initiative and you gave him this
powerful pawn structure and your bishops
are locked in so this happens very often
when you play a few moves in a row that
don't have any sense or any plan your
opponent can use them to actually get a
hold or a grip in the position and here
the position is pretty much in favor of
block but by no means is it over or
anything okay so you move he should be
one Queen d6 92 green h6 Knight c3 so
okay the Knights blockading which is
good a six yeah
okay now 95 I'm not so fond of this move
although normally you want to get the
night there and I understand that you're
running out of space
I'm a little worried about giving black
the possibility of playing D for D for
at some point and opening this bishop
against a relatively unprotected
kingside so I'm not terribly fond of
this move but it doesn't lose anything
immediately that's a good thing
Rick d 8f for g5 yeah so yeah blacks
plan is maybe a little bit more natural
than whites although I'm not so sure he
should really go for it this looks a
little strange to g5 you took that looks
normal
Thanks and 92 all right so your opponent
didn't exploit this but here you want to
get your knight to d4 right and that's
gonna lock out his rooks right I mean I
guess that's the point of putting a
knight there but if you place route d3
you're his rook kind of already bypassed
your knight so I'm not so sure what
you're gonna accomplish with this
maneuver because if you ever take this
rook you're gonna give him to past pawns
so maybe it was better to first play 92
and then push 94 because you can always
take this Knight
it's not going to run away this Knight
is already in the best query can find so
you don't have to push him or you know
you don't have to take him now until
it's a real threat from the knight and
right now the Knights only four it's
awesome it's super it looks fabulous
it's like an octopus but it could always
be taken it doesn't mean you need to
take it right now you're activating his
rook for free by taking on e4 so how do
you played ninety two first and ninety
four first and then taking on e4 then
it's a little bit more difficult for
black to make progress you do have some
strong dark squares
okay I see you've taken you for taking a
492 employed King h8 and after this this
you took with the rook now you have a
weak point on e5 but I'm not so happy
about the way he's been handling this
position he could have played this
though there's something wrong with this
let's calculate Knight f5 meets queen g6
right and now I think you have too many
things hanging because this nice hanging
and this rooks hanging right that looks
logical to me okay I'll pretend I'm
correct yeah sure looks right so what
else can he do because if you take here
then check wins the knight on the next
move that's not so good I'm not so sure
what you were going to do if you play
Bishop g5 this way but to no avail I
think because if I take this guy yeah
but you're done a full rook right and
you're getting probably checkmated so
the combination of getting checkmated
and the fact that at the most you're
going to recover one rook like let's say
yeah good good go pawn right huh if
there's actually checkmate probably
because King f1 I think you just go
route g8 now I saved one rook and I'm
don't think you can really defend this
poor in any way it looks pretty close to
checkmate if it's not it doesn't matter
if it is or not because the point is
that let's say that your pawn
accomplishes its mission and destroys
the full rook well I mean you already
lost two pawns and the rook so you only
recover the rook you know you're still
down to pawns
so maybe Bishop g5 would have been very
nasty to deal with but he didn't do that
he's nice here I don't get this move
whatever works ef-1 make sense bishop
see it now after Bishop c3 suddenly I
think the tables even might have changed
you know you have a powerful night on
the
or your Bishop is on an ice x-ray
against this king that's not followed
not feeling so comfortable anymore on
your part on e5 it's not so weak now
okay now you're better he played Bishop
g5 and now I think you're correct
now he's six is good now he has some
actual tactical problems to solve now
let's save you if he did solve them I'll
get a question okay so here here right
now let's see if there was something
better
hmm yeah time pressure kills chest but
let's see what else you could have done
feels like group takes is not correct
you should take with the night but
Bishop e6 is a hindrance I wish this
Queen was active somehow you know I'm
thinking if you ain't like just a simple
move like this sacrificing the exchange
for a long-term diagonal pressure the
idea is just to put the Queen in front
of the of the rook would work but that
wouldn't require some calculation and
might not I'm not sure so Knight a5
Bishop fe6 already your queen or f2 also
possible yeah the idea to put the Queen
takes that for Queen e5 yeah he's
talking about this move the idea that if
he ever takes you go here 25 not so bad
actually this might become dangerous for
block it's not so easy to see if he can
actually just survive the attack
yeah logic says that he should but it
you should be enough compensation for
bite all right so you took took Knight
h4 so tactics are somewhere here and
this move doesn't make sense what
whatever means knowledge for did I put
the Queen on the right way yes but a
queen on the right spot okay so this and
you cannot take the Queen right I get
that part but it says because if you
take the Queen check and suddenly
everything is hanging right because
there's a rook takes that form I get
that but it says D takes e4 maybe it was
it takes off or okay yeah so suddenly
things are not so good because he was
able to obtain the exchange and unlike
some of the variations we maybe consider
the queen is still on a2 so now okay
there's no compensation for this
exchange twin g4g three on one side ends
up happening is that he takes over the
initiative as well we can see to e3 yeah
now this isn't probably just over
because he has the extra material and
the attack rook f3 probably is not going
to help you it did not here check here
and you resign because you're gonna get
made in next one yeah
all right so your biggest problem I
think in this position in this game
besides the very opening moves stands
entirely from one move this one you know
how do you had a pawn on b2 as soon as
he goes c4 you can ignore it you don't
have to think about it but because you
don't have a pawn on me - you had to put
a lot of pieces on the queenside
tend to hold it back and that distracted
you from the kingside that ended up
being in the battlefield so that's
probably a little bit of why you lost
this game I would say it all goes the
back to the move before yeah he gave you
some chances he allowed you to go back
into the game and stuff but I would say
this is the culprit of you of why you
were worse to begin with no thank you
all right so we got one more game I
think all right so Phi is a simultaneous
exhibition right all right so we got
Feingold Jim been final Dwight and again
it's Claudia all right all right so
let's see 4 was played and we got c5 for
normal Sicilian lady 63 all right so
we're gonna start with this normal
Sicilian setup and we're gonna make a
mistake I move five all right so Bishop
e7 is a mistake and let's think a little
bit about why it's not a very bad move
but by all means it's a developing
normal move but here black really is
some there a little bit of pressure to
counter white center if you do not do
anything against white Center in the
next few moves it ends up being a little
bit annoying to deal with because in the
long run he can just kind of try to hold
it so black has a few moves to try to
rip apart blacks white Center in a
productive way usually they take our
white takes and they go d6
the point is that now after d6 is not so
clear how wide is going to develop
specifically this pot on e5 may become a
nuisance now it's possible that you
transpose back into this and some
variations
I would recommend and use this move
order in some specific scenarios because
I think that although he didn't do it I
think that here c4 can become an issue
and okay in a simultaneous exhibition I
don't really want to think about these
kind of things so it's understandable
that he didn't play it but I would be a
little bit concerned about having to
deal with these kind of positions first
of all your bishop had to move twice and
now this Knight is coming to e4 and
there's a weakness on d6 you know it
doesn't feel right there's something
wrong something went wrong so it's very
possible that Bishop e7 is already not
so accurate I play Bishop d3 okay
whatever knight c6 castles and you
develop here with b6 and I don't really
particularly like this type of
development because usually the point of
b6 in this scenario is actually
surprisingly not to put the bishop on be
silent but it's to trade it off for the
bishop on d3 that's normally in this
particular structure why they do this
because if you do the connect-the-dots
does everybody heard connect the dots
here in trust so connect the dots is
this it's this concept very basic
concept that says okay when you have a
pawn structure that's very long you
connect the dots starting at the
beginning and the end you put an arrow
and that's where you're attacking so we
put a this guy this guy this guy let's
arrow this guy so it goes like this
we're going that way so White's
attacking on the Kings side and this
bishop is instrumental to that attack
without this bishop it's impossible to
put accurate pressure on h7 that's why
this bishop is very often sought after
by black that's why they want to trade
it off but if you played the move order
knight c6 here in b6 now you can still
develop the bishop to b7 but nobody's
gonna touch that bishop on d3 and that's
the that's the the problem actually in
the main line of this if I remember
correctly pawn takes pawn takes T six
Bishop d3 Bishop e7 castles castles
Queen e2 knight c6
if this happens on white place rookie
route d1
but actually like goes every like all
around to capture this bishop they'll go
something like night before and if
Bishop c4 they go Knight a5 and it
should be five to go a6 and if this they
go b5 until they catch it because that
Bishop is that valuable they really
don't want that Bishop for life because
it's very hard for them to defend h7 in
some variations so okay you I mean
there's not like it's terrible but it's
gonna cost you some problems if you
don't get rid of this Bishop so Knight
bTW to that move is probably just bad I
don't like this night being on d2 bad
fancam bad Ben fangled that no no 92 is
wrong of course this should not go there
d6 looks fine to me now after takes
takes yes you what lost a pawn decided
not up you lost the tempo because you
have to go Bishop e7 Bishop d6 but on
the other hand this night doesn't belong
on d2 so maybe it's not so bad 94 Bishop
e7 so take some takes now your structure
in the Queen side I'm not too thrilled
about but it's not that bad and on the
other hand you have successfully
eliminated his pawn Center so by all
means this turned out to be pretty good
probably because 92 is just terrible
alright rook e1 Castle Bishop seat okay
ship c2 Knight f6 now here white at some
point because this night is so powerful
might need to play c4 weaken this square
and force you to go Knight f6
because if not think about it from
White's perspective how do I develop
this bishop not so clear I mean it
cannot go to g5 it'll just get exchanged
these two are not available no it
doesn't do anything on d2 so it's not so
clear how I can finish my development
without kicking out your knight and in
that case you want to allow him to kick
out your night before you do it
voluntarily because if you do if you
wait then d4 will be weakened but if you
play Knight f6 immediately then d4 is
not weak so it's kind of a big
reference at this point so Knight f6
Queen e2 Bishop d7 Bishop g5 okay
nothing is strong so far until now all
right you don't want to try it for sure
because you are making him kind of
forcing him to make a battery on c2 c4
against h7 and although it seems
relatively harmless because you can just
go g6 like you did long term there's
actually quite a bit of pressure on this
dark squares position on the King side
so I'm not too happy about having to
play g6 again I mean how is white going
to continue if it's not by taking on f6
so let him alright so I am Knight takes
to g6 you play Bishop h6 which looks
logical kind of although I'm more
worried about this move to be honest and
then if Bishop takes Knight takes and
then okay the Queen's the King side is
are suffering a little bit so you he
played h6 Bishop h6 rook e8 is forced
roof do you wanna see National
Development move Queen c7 24 is just
playing for tricks you know he's trying
to play something like rookie six those
rookie six and Bishop g6 or something
cruel and devastating like that so when
so when our opponents are doing cruel
and devastating things what do we do
besides null Adam well the thing the
first thing is to figure out what fuels
are attacked that they want to do this
cruel and devastating sacrifices and
here everything comes down to one
particular piece it's this Bishop on h6
that's allowing him to sacrifice all
this material or at least think about it
without the bishop on h6 he doesn't have
enough pieces on the King side to cause
any real problems that's why I think you
should probably just trade it off so yes
now you are maybe not so happy about the
position of some
the dark squares but okay you can't have
everything in life right now you know
you're trying to survive and after Queen
h4 trying to invade to h6 maybe you can
just keep the Queen at bay by playing
King g7 and maybe this is actually not
so bad for black
you're gonna patch things up on the dark
squares with h6 and then you're gonna
make white figure out how he's gonna
make progress maybe not so clear you
know there are some tactics but I don't
see anything working here for white so I
think it should be okay this should look
it looks a little scary but it shouldn't
be so bad but the important thing is
that I got rid of this Bishop with the
bishop on h6 I mean you can see that h4
now he's thinking about h5 takes he's
thinking about killing you somehow don't
let your opponents have any thoughts
like this so h4 he played 95 so you
trade some pieces off that's always good
and now you traded off the bishop so now
this is improving actually I'm not so
sure he should have allowed all these
trades but whatever Queen g5 years
all right so I'm afraid to recommend the
following move because it violates a few
rules of chess but I think your best and
maybe you only move was to play h6
the problem with Queen e7 is that after
h6 check you are in a permanent weakness
scenario you will never get rid of this
weakness ever ever if you trade Queens
it's still a problem because your king
is not safe ever this kind of permanent
weaknesses are very problematic because
they linger all the way into the endgame
imagine an endgame scenario in which all
of the major pieces have been traded off
and my King has wandered to the Queen
side and I play the move f6 for some
reason or another maybe to give my King
some scope or some loft and then white
plays Bishop takes g6 and then pawn
takes 2 6 H 7 h8 Queen
yeah this is a very long-term scenario
but there's our little advantages that
really add up at some point
not to mention then okay I don't like
your position of your king right now I
think you needed to kick the Queen away
and let's say that it goes to g4 because
I don't see a better Square for it
g4 will do you can play g5 and now okay
again it's not like I'm super thrilled
about your position there are some
problems but immediately I don't see how
white can take advantage of your
position he cannot play a four because
you can take it with the Queen he cannot
really put the Queen on this diagonal
and even if he did I have ways of
holding against it so that's not an
immediate loss so you know you're
holding on but after Queen e7 h6 what
ends up happening is that this King is
already suffering maybe too much King g8
I think I guess Queen v f6 I think f6 is
what it says
I'm assuming it's f6 it's something to
desex I'm not sure what it is I'm gonna
assume it's Queen d6 King f7 and Bishop
e3 so now why it's definitely better but
you are
okay what's blacks probably lost see you
had to weaken yourself with f6 there was
no choice really I mean you can maybe
have played Queen f8 but that's a sad
move if you play f6 though this happens
your pawns are dying because if you
trade trade this is dying so I have to
play this I have to play room c6 and
nobody's gonna defend this guy and then
this is still a problem yeah this is
very close to lost to already losing but
not so maybe a little bit better than
Bishop defied
right I think you missed a little tactic
here at the end and then Feingold very
cleverly instead of taking with the
Bishop because then after Queen takes d6
it's black that wins he takes with the
rook taking advantage of the fact that
you cannot take here because Rookie 7
right so now after takes takes we're in
the same situation we just analyzed but
while you're missing a bishop from b7 so
this is not so happy for black I think
you resigned here yeah I mean it was
already obviously losing Feingold is not
going to forgive this position not even
blindfolded so that was actually quite
interesting a couple of interesting
games lots to learn off a little bit of
mistakes in the opening but not
disasters and I think that it's
important to understand that there are a
lot of little inaccuracies that happen
all the time in especially in amateur
games in the opening that can be very
easily fixed if you analyze the game
some grandmasters they develop a certain
way for a certain reason and what ends
up happening is a lot of people have
these vague ideas like okay I know in
this position white played a three well
I know that in this position you played
h3 like and again then we just so I know
that in this position you kind of go b6
I'm not sure why but you go b6 and then
it's not so clear why to you so you go
and make it up over the border maybe
you're right maybe you're wrong but if
you looked at a grandmaster game or any
grandmaster game in this variation you
would see oh they've always played b6
and then 90% of the time they put the
bishop on a6 not on b7 so it kind of
there you fixed it that was a problem in
the open you fixed it already boom so
understanding why you play certain moves
really helps your game it's not so much
about whether it's a mistake or not but
it allows you kind of a platform to
understand where you're going with this
game you know you played a certain moves
why did I play them and how is this
gonna affect the rest of my game how am
I gonna continue and finish the
development of my pieces and where are
my where are my plants lying and all
those little details add to more
comfortable positions and usually the
player with a more comfortable position
and stop being victorious 90% of chess
games
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]